NARRATOR: 554 solar days
after the Mars Curiosity Rover
touched down, it
beams its latest
high-resolution
panoramic photographs
of the Mars landscape to Earth.
Upon inspection, amateur
archaeologists announce
a startling discovery--
what appears to be an
effigy located at the gap
resembling a human statue.
The find is just
one of the dozens
of strange earth-like objects
cited in the Rover images,
including a
sarcophagus, a Buddha
statue, and even a cross.
The Rover images are
generally fairly close up,
and it is possible
to spot things
like statue heads
and stone blocks,
sometimes with writing
on carvings in them.
It's such a shame they do so
much to destroy these images.
But basically, what they
do is the resize them down
so that the details are lost.
But, because I've worked in
photographic restoration,
I know how to do it.
All I've done with this is
actually enhanced the contrast
and sharpened it a little bit.
The details I noticed first were
particularly the eye and nose
details on the front of the
statue on the left here,
with a very quite
clear mouth structure,
and what looks like
an ear just here.
And you have a long,
narrow, elongated cone
head shape to the statue.
Now, this may well be
an elaborate headdress
on this statue here, which
seems to be broken off,
but it's hard to say for sure.
I mean, this is a damaged
statue buried up to its chin,
and there's probably
a lot more of it
buried just below in the sand.
But you can actually see quite
clearly the sort of thing
you would expect to find
somewhere like a Central
or South America.
NARRATOR: Might there actually
be ruins of a lost civilization
scattered across the
Martian landscape,
ruins that mirror those that
exist on our own planet?
Ancient astronaut
theorists say yes,
and propose that this is one
of many artifacts on Mars
that seem to have
counterparts on our Earth.
Certain structures on Mars
may be completely related
to structures here on earth.
On Mars, we have structures
that look like pyramids.
There are standing stones
and Stonehenge-type
of structures on Mars.
There's also a structure on
Mars that looks like a Sphinx.
MALE SPEAKER: Around Cydonia,
there are many, many objects,
including an area called The
City, where the so-called face
on Mars is located.
There's a massive
pentagonal pyramid.
There's a cluster of
other pyramid objects
that are nearby.
And one of the things that's
really interesting about The
City is that some people have
pointed out that if you take
the apex of all of the pyramids
structures there-- and there
are a number of them--
that they basically match
the layout of the Pleiades.
Now, this is something that
we've seen here on Earth.
We've seen various ancient
architectural monuments
that are also laid out to
reflect the constellation
of the Pleiades.
GIORGIO A. TSOUKALOS:
Is it possible
that the structures on Mars are
real and of artificial origin?
That is something where all of
science says no, impossible.
Well, is it really?
Water on Mars,
impossible, right?
No.
It has been proven.
So we have to ask ourselves,
what civilization built this,
and what happened to them?
And some have
suggested that they
actually escaped Mars
and came to earth
to ensure their survival.
WILLIAM HENRY: When we look to
these extraordinary structures
on Earth similar to what
we're now seeing on Mars,
it makes you wonder, did
our ancient extraterrestrial
ancestors teach humans how
to build these monuments,
knowing that one day we would
rediscover our roots on Mars
and be able to match up what
we've done on Earth with what
we had already done on Mars?
NARRATOR: Might the various
structures and artifacts
found on the surface
of Mars really
be evidence of a past Martian
civilization, a civilization
that was recreated on Earth?
If so, why would NASA try
to hide this connection,
and might there be more that
the public isn't being told?